>>IT MAY NOT HAVE AFFECTED THE
OUTCOME OF THE 2016 ELECTION,
BUT THE RUSSIANS WERE ABLE TO
PULL OFF A WIDE RANGING AND
AGGRESSIVE ATTEMPT TO INTERFERE
WITH THE CAMPAIGN.
CAN WE STOP THEM FROM DOING IT
AGAIN?
LET'S ASK AN OLD FRIEND, JIM
WOOLSEY.
THIS INDICTMENT TODAY WAS WILD.
THEY WERE ORGANIZING ALL SORTS
OF THINGS.
THEY WERE WORKING FOR THAT JILL
STEIN, TRYING TO HELP HER.
THEY WERE ANTI-TRUMP AND
PRO-TRUMP ON ONE DAY AFTER THE
ELECTION.
WHAT'S THAT ALL ABOUT?
>> THEY WANT TO BE A FORCE AND
THEY WANT TO DISRUPT THINGS.
THEY CALL THEIR BIG OVERALL
PROGRAM DISINFORMATION.
AND THEY'VE BEEN DOING THIS
SINCE THE 1920S, 1930S.
WHAT'S NEW IS THEY DO IT WITH
CYBER.
THEY DIDN'T HAVE MUCH LUCK
DISRUPTING AMERICAN ELECTIONS
BACK IN THE 1930S OR 1940S.
BUT THEY'VE BEEN DOING THAT
OTHER COUNTRIES ALL ALONG.
THE HEAD OF ROMANIA INTELLIGENCE
>>SO FAR NOT THE SAME WAY THE
RUSSIANS DO.
BUT THE RUSSIANS -- I DON'T
KNOW.
THEY PHOTOSHOP PHOTOGRAPHS OF
THE POPE TO MAKE HIM LOOK LIKE
HE'S SALUTING TO A GERMAN NAZI
OFFICER.
>> YOU DON'T THINK THE CHINESE
ARE INVOLVED IN THIS TYPE OF
ACTIVITY?
THEY HAVE AN ECONOMY THAT DWARFS
RUSSIA.
I THINK IT'S IMPORTANT THAT WE
STOP THIS RUSSIAN STUFF.
BUT EVERY TIME SOMEONE SAYS
RUSSIA, RUSSIA, RUSSIA, I SAY
CHINA, CHINA, CHINA.
>> THAT'S RIGHT.
SMARTER.
THE RUSSIANS BASICALLY ARE LIKE
THE OLD FELLOW WHO LIVED NEXT TO
THE LINCOLNS AND THEIR FARM WHEN
THEY WERE A LITTLE BIT.
HE USED TO SAY, I DON'T NEED
MUCH LAND, JUST WHAT ADJOINS
MINE.
THAT'S RUSSIA.
>> BUT THEY HAVE AN ECONOMY
SMALLER THAN THE SIZE OF FRANCE.
COME ON.
COMPARED TO CHINA.
CHINA'S EATING OUR LUNCH ON SO
MANY FRONTS.
>> AND IT GIVES US SOME
LEVERAGE.
IF WE CAN WORK TO GET THE PRICE
OF OIL DOWN, WE WILL CREATE A
VERY, VERY UNHAPPY PUTIN.
>> BUT WE DON'T WANT TO PUSH
RUSSIA TO CHINA, THOUGH.
THAT'S THE LAST THING WE WANT.
>> WE JUST WANT TO WEAKEN THEM
BECAUSE WE CAN DEAL WITH THEM A
LOT BETTER IF THEY'RE WEAK.
I WAS NEGOTIATING THE TREATY IN
'89 WHEN THE BERLIN WALL WENT
DOWN.
AND YOU'VE NEVER SEEN SUCH
RUSSIANS.
>>WE ARE SOON GOING TO BECOME
THE LARGEST EXPORTER OF ENERGY
IN THE WORLD.
ISN'T THAT A WEAPON AGAINST
RUSSIAN EXPANSIONISM?
>> IT'S GOOD BUT IT'S REALLY
ABOUT A BALANCE OF PAYMENTS.
WHAT MATTERS MORE IS THE PRICE.
YOU GET THE PRICE DOWN IN THE
30S AND 40S AND YOU CAN DO IT
JUST BY --
>>WELL, WE HAVE A GLUT OF
ENERGY BEING PRODUCED WITH
FRACKING AND EVERYTHING ELSE.
>> THAT HELPS.
BUT TO GET THE PRICE DOWN, YOU
CAN GIVE PEOPLE AN INCENTIVE TO
HAVE WHO FUELS TO CHOOSE FROM AT
THE FILLING STATION.
AND THEN ONCE YOU DO THAT,
YOU'VE GOT ARBITRAGE THAT TAKES
THE PRICE OF OIL DOWN.
THE RUSSIANS CARE ABOUT THAT A
LOT.
>> OBAMA DIDN'T DO MUCH IN
RESPONSE TO THIS MEDDLING IN OUR
ELECTION.
THEY KNEW BACK IN 2014, LONG
BEFORE TRUMP GOT INTO THE MIX,
THAT THIS WAS A PROBLEM.
AS FAR AS I COULD TELL, THEY
ALLOWED THAT URANIUM ONE SALE TO
GO THROUGH WITH THAT COMMITTEE.
>> BAD CALL.
>> YEAH.
SO THAT HELPED RUSSIA.
>> SURE.
>> WHAT DO WE DO?
HOW DO WE STOP THIS IN THE
FUTURE?
WEAKEN THEM ECONOMICALLY AND
THEN WHAT?
>> I THINK WHAT WE REALLY WANT
IS TO GET THEM TO START PULLING
IN THEIR HORNS AND COMING BACK
OUT OF GEORGIA, BACK OUT OF
UKRAINE.
WE NEED TO TURN THEM AROUND
BECAUSE THEY ARE TAKING OVER,
EVEN WITH THEIR MILITARY AND
OTHER INADD
OTHER INAEQ
OTHER INAEQUA
OTHER INAEQUAC
OTHER INAEQUACY
OTHER INAEQUAIE
OTHER INAEQUAIES
OTHER INAEQUINE
OTHER INAEQUINAD
OTHER INAEQUINADEQ
OTHER INAEQUINADEQUA
OTHER INAEQUINADEQUACI
OTHER INAEQUINADEQUACIES
OTHER INAEQUINADEQUACIES.
>> HAVE WE EVER TRIED TO MEDDLE
IN OTHER COUNTRY'S ELECTIONS?
>> OH, PROBABLY, BUT IT WAS FOR
THE GOOD OF THE SYSTEM IN ORDER
TO AVOID THE COMMUNISTS FROM
TAKING OVER.
FOR EXAMPLE --
>>WE DON'T DO THAT NOW THOUGH?
>> ONLY FOR A VERY GOOD CAUSE